good morning everybody
and welcome to this latest meeting of
the trafford
coving 19 public engagement board
on attendances i have today apologies
from
councillors denise weston councillor
chilton uh
sarah radcliffe joanne gibson tom
maloney and michelle hall
and my thanks to all of you that are in
attendance this morning
uh item two on the agenda are there any
declarations of interest
i don't see any at all thank you and
uh minutes of the last meeting held on
the 30th of june
2021 can we take those as read please as
an accurate record
uh thank you silences golden
so moving on to item four the update on
kobe 19
situation in trafford just before i
invite eleanor on
i think i'd like to say as chair we're
increasing difficult position in terms
of the infection rating trap but i note
it's almost doubled since we last met
and it's well into the 500s which is the
highest it's ever been throughout the
whole this pandemic intrepid
yesterday we had 3483 pupils
self-isolating of which 277 had covered
across the borough
and i pick up off the mainstream news
this morning that the netherlands has
seen a 500
rise in infection cases since lifting
nearly all their restrictions
and we're faced with that from the 19th
so i think
uh um we've got some really difficult
times ahead
in terms of our messaging but on that ba
on that note i'll hand over to eleanor
to give us the latest update elena thank
you
thank you very much councillor freeman
and you are absolutely right we
we are now at um up to last
um thursday friday we
are on about 540 cases per hundred
thousand which is the highest we've ever
been in trafford as you said
um and we're seeing these across all of
that we're seeing
um unfortunately increase in every age
group now
most our highest case rates are in our
under 45 population
and within the very highest rates are in
our 17 to 24 year olds
but all of those all of the people under
45 got rates of
um around about 600 per hundred thousand
or upwards and substantially upwards in
in some cases um we
are seeing cases across the whole of the
borough all of our wards have cake rates
of over 300 per hundred thousand
um there's a when you look at ward based
data there is volatility because
um obviously the the numbers become
smaller per ward
but we have um rates of over 900 100 000
in some of our central wards ashton or
mersey
um in particular has had very high rates
but
it at the moment the awards are sort of
taking over from each other
as to which ones are particularly high
at a particular point
in a number of cases we've seen um high
numbers
of children being sent home with either
symptoms or then when being tested
asymptomatic cases but
very very it's had a massive impact on
our schools
over the last couple of weeks and um
many of the children who are up
affected are symptomatic um we
we're not obviously expecting serious
illness in this
in in children but it's a very
unpleasant illness for a number of
children
and and helen will talk more later about
the impact on schools and our planning
for september
for the school's return
so what do we do and what
are we going to do so i was just going
to some
give a quick summary of where i think
we're at in trafford and what i think we
need to be planning for
with the restrictions lifting on the
19th and i think
i think we all know that as soon as the
announcement is made about restrictions
lifting
and so probably from the fifth we've
really started to see behaviors change
um and we need to and and you know our
rates are just going to
keep going up for certainly i think it's
anticipated that
we won't hit the peak in rates in the
northwest
until the middle of august at the
earliest
um every other time we've got to these
sort of high rates we've then imposed
restrictions
so this is the first time that we we are
seeing what happens if you don't impose
restrictions and of course we're in a
very very different position now than we
were a year ago because of the
vaccination program
so if i just run through really the sort
of four key areas that i think we should
be focusing on in trafford
so that we can we can get to that point
of living with cobit
because at whatever point we lifted
restrictions we were going to see
an increase in in in cases because even
though that the vaccination program
is very good and the very the reach is
very good and the vaccine itself is
extremely effective
there are always going to be some people
who aren't vaccinated for
for whatever reason either because of
health reasons or obviously children
because of age or because they choose
not to or
because even if you are vaccinated no
vaccine is 100 effective in everybody
and while it's it's a vaccine that's
designed to prevent hospitalization and
death
and that means that there will always be
some people who will continue to be ill
even if they're vaccinated and there
will be some people who can transmit
that continue to transmit the virus
so i think we were expecting to see we
are
expecting to see an increase in cases
and
the argument for releasing the
restrictions now
is i think a good one in that in the
summer time you have less other things
going around so you're more likely
to have more capacity in hospitals and
you're more likely to have a healthier
population
because all the flu the colds all the
winter vomiting diseases etc aren't
circulating at the same time so the
weather is on our side
by releasing the restrictions now but
that doesn't
releasing restrictions is not the same
as just letting the
virus do what it wants and to let it run
rampant
because if we do that we will see
hospitalizations we will see deaths and
we have to work out how we're going to
take control
and i suppose the other thing i want to
say is that public health and the
economy have been pitted against
each other quite often but actually
there is no health without wealth and
there's no wealth without health
we have to have a vibrant economy
to be healthy but to be to have a
vibrant economy we have to be healthy as
well you can't operate
in in a society where a virus is running
unchecked because
your workforce is ill you have no people
to go to the cinema the pubs the clubs
you have you have no economy if you
don't have a healthy workforce
and we know that a a workforce
an unhealthy workforce and and a
workforce with like
high numbers of long-term conditions and
so on is a work
is an economy with low productivity so
we have to make sure that we have a
healthy workforce or we don't have an
economy
so i just wanted to say it's they're not
different they're the same
so we are now trying to think about how
do we
re how with no with the restrictions
lifted do we make sure that we don't
have a massive further impact on both
population health
and then that hit on our economy that
would follow so i would say there are
four things that we need to be doing
in trafford the first thing is we need
to be keeping an eye on the public
health measures those
core infection prevention control
measures some of which we
we can have under our own control so
that's things like
wearing a face mask in the supermarket
or when you're on a
on a tram or a train or a bus you know
keep keep doing that that it will
it will protect others it may give you
some protection if
nothing else is courteous way to behave
to the staff who are working in those
settings
um hand washing hand washing protects
not only from covid but from all sorts
of other things
including stomach bugs etc so really
important that we keep
that going the social the physical
distancing social isolation keeping
those two meters apart
meeting two meeting people outside
wherever you can
all the things where you can do it you
should do it if you want to go to a
nightclub
you are not going to be socially
distancing and you're not going to be
wearing a mask are you that
is you know that's the point of a
nightclub but actually if you're in a
supermarket
if you're on a train if you're another
if you're at work
you don't need to be really close to
people so try and respect everybody's
physical space
and and work from home where you can
because if people are taking more risks
in other areas of their lives
it's better to not to take risks the
risks you can control
you shouldn't do so if you're going to
go to a nightclub which is great
and i'm you know not for me
but anymore but in the past and you know
i know my children are desperate to get
out dancing again
and quite right too but that means
think about who you're then going to
visit you know don't go and see
you know do be careful about older
relations we do need to protect
each other um so so making sure that we
we abide by those public health measures
and remember our own personal
responsibility and i would say
that you know it would be great if um if
we don't get government advice i would
really hope that a greater manchester we
can give some advice about continuing to
wear face coverings
in health and social care settings we
will absolutely be supporting our nhs
colleagues
and asking anyone who is going into any
health or social care
setting please wear continue to wear the
face covering that setting
i think that should continue on public
transport as well
and then we'll be talking and then
thinking about the ventilation keeping
windows open
etc so all that public health measures
boring
but important the next thing is
vaccination
and our vaccination program i mean we
should be so proud as a country of
how well we've done with our vaccination
program we are making amazing steps
we've got
um and rebecca angela will talk later
about how well we're doing the
proportion we've got
covered now you've seen that in the data
briefing we're doing an amazing job but
there are still
people who aren't vaccinated and we need
to really support and encourage people
not only to take that first job but also
the second one and then in september
when boosters get offered
if you're in the groups that get a
booster offer plea please do take
advantage of that the third thing i
think we should be doing and this is
general public health point and then
it's again my very boring public health
points but actually your general
physical health and your general measure
mental health really matter and they
matter for everything they don't just
matter for covid
so we know we have high rates of
premature death from cancer and
cardiovascular disease
and the things that prevent those
conditions also
supportive to prevent harm from covid
so keep an eye on your weight um if you
don't have scales and you don't want to
and you can't be bothered with
calculating your bmi
i would encourage people to get a piece
of string measure a piece of string the
same as your height
double it over if it goes around your
waist doubled over
that's fine if it doesn't go around your
waist you need to start losing weight
so um have a have a play with that
at home and see where you get to we've
got lots
of support services around weight
management but also think about alcohol
anybody who's still smoking really
really encourage people to stop smoking
we don't need people having lung cancer
on top of other respiratory diseases
and obviously smoking's a big risk
factor for cardiovascular disease as
well
and keep physically active and keep
keep am i you know be mindful of your
mental health and the impact your mental
health has
because again there's no health without
good mental health
as well and the final thing i think we
need to be doing as a borough
is creating a common purpose we are
still all in this together
and we all do need to pull together and
we need to think about the risks that we
pose to ourselves the risks that we're
putting ourselves in and the risks
that we pose to others and so i would
say to all employers and businesses
if you've been able to manage with your
staff working from home up to now
continue to get them to work from home
because that way people will
that's one less risk that people are
exposing themselves to
and it means that people are able to do
more in their personal lives
if they're able to do their work life
from home so
all of these things are a careful
balancing of risks we do this every day
and we're going to have to get
used to continuing to do this but it's
it's making sure that we take
responsibility for ourselves but also we
think about our impact on others
and we support others to live that
healthy life and reduce the risk that
they pose
while at the same time allowing the
people who've really suffered through
this
i think in terms of the constraints that
have put
been put on their lifestyles and that i
mean by that are particularly our young
our under-30s population who really do
deserve a break from this
and do deserve to be out in the
nightclubs do deserve to be out dancing
and singing
but um how can we make sure that they
don't then you know
again if they can work from home let's
make sure that they continue to do so
and we manage our risks
collectively and respectfully so that's
that's my little rant for today
thank you alana and before invite
questions i know we've discussed this
week about the messaging we're going to
be putting out and very much our
messaging
is going to reflect the very values that
you
you've explained to us there um and i've
no doubt maybe we can bring
ellie in later on to talk about uh to
talk some more about that if
that's okay yeah uh any questions then
please for
uh yes julia councillor new grosh
thank you very much so i'm thinking
about uh
the changes coming along on the 19th um
mask wearing is particularly one that
i'm concerned about we're removing the
obligation to wear do we have in greater
manchester
any control over or say on the wearing
of masks
for example transport for greater
manchester can we give them guidance
i'm aware that the mayor of london has
imposed that as a condition of carriage
on the underground
i think that's something we're going to
have to look into with with our
relationship with transport for greater
manchester and i'm not sure that
the mayor here has all of the same
rights as the mayor in
london but i don't know if councillor
freeman knows more
about what the relationship is we will
certainly be from public health point of
view we'll be giving this as guidance
but i think the difficulty we've got is
that we know that there are some people
who are very much against wearing masks
for all sorts of reasons
and it's been very difficult in some of
our settings including on transport
as soon as people are told they don't
have to do things a lot of people have
changed them you know have decided not
to
i think at the moment all we can do is
try and
implore people and um if we if we can
get
a stronger stronger advice then i think
we should but at the moment we are
quite often just working with um trying
to get people to understand the impact
it has on others
of not doing some of these behaviors
i've got i've got to bring two others a
bit before i do um
i think that the mayor has already uh
declared that he's very much in favor of
the wearing of masks on
public transport but whether he can
actually enforce it isn't a matter
um i've got a question from dorothy
evans please then uh counselor akanola
dorothy yes excuse me
it's just with the um the rising
infection rates and
we're opening up next week certainly
from a provider perspective
what's the advice on testing
so my advice on testing and we're
waiting to is that we should continue
with all the infection prevention
control measures that are in place at
the moment
because the risk hasn't changed and the
reason we had those measures in place
for example the
um asking people to do to regular
lateral flow testing and so on
was because of the risk that was being
posed to them the risk
is increasing not decreasing so i would
strongly recommend
all anyone working in a health and
social care setting where you were
already asking staff
and where possible service users and i
know it's not always possible to our
service users to test
but i would strongly recommend that all
of those
providers continue to to do the same and
not
make any changes to their current
infection prevention and control
procedures obviously i can't instruct
people to do that
but that's my advice
thank you uh counselor you have a
question
achilles you're on mute
sorry first one today and
my question also was about health and
social care where
i'm really concerned that in care homes
in particular where staff have had to
wear masks
when they're within two meters of
service users and they had to have
regular testing
that now that the guide
my understanding is now that the
restrictions are releasing though that
guidance is
is going to change within care homes and
it's going to be a
must it's going to be can you rather
than must
and i'm concerned about how do um
providers manage their staff when i know
for me in particular in my service
i've had great trouble getting some
stuff i know vaccination is different
but some are refusing to vaccinate but i
had big arguments getting people to even
be tested
and i'm really concerned now that
especially with everything rising
that without that guidance of saying you
must test and therefore you can't work
here if you don't test
that um we're gonna see massive rises in
some of the care homes that have not
been hit
i think i mean obviously one of our
biggest concerns is how to protect some
of our most vulnerable
residents and people living in care
homes just by
very nature of the fact that their
health is likely to be poor
and also living in a residential setting
increases the risk
so we the advice we're giving to care
homes and and to be fair i think most of
the care homes will
will want to follow this advice is that
they should ask
people to continue to follow all of the
ip the infection prevention and control
guidance
and all the measures that they were
using previously i think most of our
care home
providers will be pleased to follow that
guidance and i do think
where staff are saying well i won't wear
a mask or whatever i don't think that's
unless the staff member has
a um a good medical reason not to be
wearing a mask
i think it would be quite within the
organization's rights who insist that
they continue to take those prevention
measures
both for their safety and the safety of
their of the
of the people that they care for and
after all even before
things like that you know we've often
had times where it's we've only been
able to use guidance
um so before the smoking ban for example
um
you you could have been technically you
could have smoked anywhere but most pla
many many workplaces had a ban on
smoking
even before the ban the smoking ban came
in so i do think
um that we we have you know just because
the all the guidance
it now just because we're operating with
guidance now doesn't mean that we can't
enforce it quite strictly
particularly but probably more on that
risk assessed basis where you can
actually demonstrate to the staff
why that risk is high and what the risk
to to the people that they care for
will be if they don't if they don't
abide by that guidance
and that would certainly be the line i
would be taking
i'm i i do hope as well that our unions
will work with us on this
to make sure because you know from a
from a staff point of view
wearing that mask keeping the making
sure that you have the correct ppe that
you're taking the infection prevention
control measures
it it helps protect the people you're
working with but of course it gives you
a lot of protection as well
so it is a really important two-way
thing protect yourself
and protect others
thank you ellen accounts accordingly
mike we can't hear you can't hear
anything you're saying
i still can't hear you but like at all
there's nothing coming through shall i
come back to you mike
what when you sort your tech problems
out okay can i go on to councillor
blackburn please
thank you just following on um aquila's
question um do we have any data
as to the um numbers
or percentages of the care workers
who've had
the two vaccinations um you know we're
working
working just in care homes obviously it
might be a little bit more difficult
to to assess the numbers of carers that
you know that go
in into people's homes yes so we collect
that data and we've got good
uptake in almost all of our care homes
and there are a couple of homes where
we're doing more work with the staff to
try and encourage them
but we we are continuing to work with
staff as um as groups as
and as individuals to support them to
get that vaccination
and we keep records of that of all of
that
and i'm sure rebecca will talk more
about the work we're doing there
yeah could i just ask have there been
any older people in the care homes
who have not wanted to be vaccinated
i think we've got hardly any people
of the residents who haven't wanted
vaccination i can't say it's 100
but it's it's very very high levels of
uptake within the um
residents of care homes and they they
were offered
um vaccination obviously very early and
vaccines were taken out to them
so we've got a really you know the care
homes have been really really strong
throughout on all of this they have been
they have offered such
you know care homes and schools have
just excelled in this whole
whole pandemic okay thank you
uh thank you council blackburn council
corner have you sorted it out
no uh i'll go to andrew latham then
thank you
do you want to put your question
counselor coordinator in the in the
group chat
thank you andrew hi thanks i just wanted
to raise a point about pcr testing if if
i may
we've had some feedback this week from
someone trying to access a
test for their daughter that the
questions around the symptoms haven't
been updated in line with the
new guidance on the new symptoms to look
for
so that if and they
so when you're asked about what symptoms
you're presenting if you don't specify
the
previous ones you're told you're
ineligible whereas the new symptoms
are those that they were presenting with
so they basically had to
lie to say that they were experiencing
the original ones just to access the
test
so i just wanted to to raise that i
don't i don't know who would be
responsible for
for picking that up so it's um the
national
um public health internationally is
still
um advising people only to get a test
if they have one of the three core
symptoms so the loss of taste and smell
the cough a persistent cough or the
fever but what we are seeing especially
with a lot of younger people
is we're seeing a much broader range of
um symptoms
including a persistent headache extreme
fatigue
flu-like symptoms and a sore throat
and sometimes diarrhea and vomiting and
what we are advising people locally to
do is
if in doubt take a test and you can tick
on the box
local authority requested as
as a as an option for the testing we're
also asking anyone who's the contact for
case to go for a pcr test
and again that would be that local
authority request so
at the moment the core symptoms have not
changed
but locally i would say if you feel ill
and you have any of those symptoms don't
go to work don't go to school
see how you're doing um if you're not
better
and it starts to feel you know you start
feeling worse go for that pcr test
if you feel you have symptoms um and
don't rely
if you have got symptoms don't rely on
the lateral flow test
you do need that pcr test is much more
accurate
we we are in constant conversation with
public health england
about whether they are going to formally
change their symptom list
thanks helen the accounts according
these questions now in the chat in the
chat he says my question was simply
whether
most of the euro released infection at
least to the semis has worked through
trajectory of infection
the rice seems consistent without a euro
um any comments on that elena at all
please
so the infections do take a little while
to come through
um so anyone who is in fact who
was infected on sunday we wouldn't start
seeing those through coming through to
the
end of this week um also because
what we always see is infection rights
rates rise most quickly in our younger
population
and they you've got more of that
population who may be symptom-free
and therefore they might not be aware of
it so it may not you know we don't
sometimes don't see the infection
until you've got more older people
infected and of course the vaccination
program
is meaning that more of more of those of
us who are older
maybe would be infected but the vaccine
will will not will
mean that we'd have very mild symptoms
if any
so um i think it's going to be a bit of
a slow burn on this one
i don't think we're over i think we will
see a big bump with the
with the euros um and all the
celebrating
um and then the commiserating
um but it it it will start showing
through
over this next week or two i think
and what's most worrying i think on our
data we are what we're doing locally is
we're really keeping a close eye on all
of the cases and people over 75
so that we can understand where those
people are where they might have in fact
got infected from other other household
members infected and so on
and we are that the over 75 rates were
staying
quite stable but they have now started
to increase
thank you ellen are there any further
questions before we move on on the
agenda
i don't cindy thank you very much indeed
can we therefore move on to item five
which is a self-isolation pathfinder
update and i invite kirsty johnson to
speak on this kirsty
no is she not with us today um she's
she's expecting a call into the meeting
chair so i'll just send her the meeting
she'll join us in a minute or two
whilst we're waiting then shall we just
move on to work mass testing with uh
with ben
yeah that's absolutely fine thank you
very much chair um
so i think some of this already has been
touched on by elena but i'm trying to
give a quick update in terms
of the changes um we heard about in the
last week
then talk about some of the work that we
were doing around testing and then
finally some key messages
so in terms of some of those changes
then so from a symptomatic testing
perspective if you are close contacting
the 16th of august
rather than self-isolating you're going
to be asked to go and get a pcr test
so the meantime that hasn't changed but
just to kind of emphasize that that pcr
testing
um will increase going forward from the
16th of august
when it comes to asymptomatic testing so
that's testing if you have any symptoms
um secondary school pupils are going to
be asked to take
two tests at the start of their return
in september
um our testing team are going to be
offering support two schools on this
so a webinar direct training over at the
town hall or
you know coming into schools themselves
and a kind of top tips document as well
that we're pulling together
um secondary schools will then be
expected to return to twice
weekly um home tests throughout
september we're still waiting on clarity
as to what's going to happen after that
september period
so i think um helen will talk a bit more
about the widest
the wider school stuff but that's just
the kind of quick update on the
testing-wise
um so in terms of our activity recently
um we've now finished providing our
additional support to schools that we do
because we've seen that obviously
massive increase in rates
um so that was um testing pairs and
cares in primary schools and the whole
school testing of pupils in
secondary schools in total we've
supported then
over the past month or so five primary
schools six secondary schools
two businesses and that's not to mention
door knocking and additional handing out
what your flow home tests
so in total we carried out an additional
four thousand
four hundred and seventy seven tests and
handed out over three thousand likes to
flow home test kits
so really fantastic effort um from from
the testing team during that time period
and we're obviously going to be focused
um on businesses and hospitality over
that kind of summer period our school's
closed
um key bit i want to emphasize here is
in terms of that pcr demand
um now we know obviously um
demand for testing is rising anyway and
we already seen
people who aren't being able to go and
book um
currently testing sites when they're
trying to get a pcr test
we think from everything we've heard so
far the key reason for this
is is staffing out those sites um so
it's not the case
that results going back slowly it's more
just the case that capacity at those
sites
is a little bit reduced at the moment um
the key advice
we're giving is if you are struggling to
go and access a pcr test at a site a
try again later more slots are released
all the time so keep going
and b if you're still really struggling
you can still go and book a
home pci kit should turn up within about
24 hours
and all you do is post it back
afterwards um so i think that's our
key message on that bit and in terms of
i guess the key overall messages and as
we said before if you have symptoms
get a pcr test don't reassure yourself
with the lateral flow test and as
eleanor spoken about continue with
testing especially in those kind of key
hospitality settings of business
settings
and electrical flow tests is only
effective if you do it on a regular
basis
so there's no point just having a kind
of one-off lecture flow test every now
and again so it to be effective it's
really kind of crucial to make sure that
people are testing on that twice
weekly basis so that's the key updates
from me
in terms of testing thank you very much
thank you ben any questions at all for
ben
i don't see any hands raised at all
thank you ben um is um kirsty with us
or yet or are we still waiting
i don't see it so we'll move on again to
uh contact racing and outbreak
management
kate is that down for you
um i think it's me chair helen
yeah gone helen sorry thanks okay um so
since the uh change in guidance
we're still waiting for operational
guidance around um
the approach we need to take for contact
tracing locally
um but just to say from the 19th of july
nhs test and trace
the national system will pick up schools
contact racing again we're still waiting
to understand the detail behind that
and from the 16th of august anyone who's
got
both vaccinations um and anyone under
the age of 18
will no longer have to self-isolate they
go for a pcr test
um so anyone who isn't vaccinated will
have to self-isolate so that's the
current guidance that we're looking at
at the moment
we're continuing to run all our systems
as we have been
to this point and through august just to
ensure that
we can provide as much support to our
traffic residents and businesses
and while the national system and the
new approach kind of beds in because
what we want to do is
contain any further transmission as much
as possible
so just say we are waiting for
operational guidance at the moment
around contact racing
would you like me to continue to talk
about uh schools chair can i just ask
about that
uh as part of it we have at the moment a
pretty strong control over outbreak
management at schools
we're having daily updates on the number
of pupils that have self-isolated the
number of pupils that have contracted a
number of staff
how do we expect it when it moves to
national control how how is it going to
affect us i i just see
i i it gives me some concerns i know
schools break up next week
but we then got the issue then coming
back in september
and i just wonder what the rationale or
the
uh the thinking behind this move by by
the government is because we have
what i consider to be a really robust
system in place at the moment
i think that's a really good question
and elena may want to come in and
comment further on this but
um i think i think some of the rationale
is about trying to get
public health and schools back to
business as usual as much as they
possibly can we've got
we're into our second year really of
academic disruption aren't we for
children
and so it's really thinking about how we
can free up schools to really focus and
get back to business as usual in
education
but locally what we are doing and um we
have developed a framework
which mirrors the national guidance but
provides a local offer
so like you said we've got really strong
working relationships with all our
schools
um and it's worked incredibly well um
and so
what we've done is developed a framework
which means that schools can still
notify us directly as they always have
done
we can support them in the early
intervention looking at the contact
tracing and helping them that way
we're working very closely with ben's
team around all the testing offer
looking at the communications that go
out to schools and parents
um doing a piece of work around
vaccinations so we're looking to
see how many of our education staff
across the whole spectrum of education
haven't had the vaccination yet
due to hesitancy or access and then
potentially working with rebecca's team
to put on a specific kind of targeted
session just for education staff
so we are looking to make sure that we
have that safety net underneath
the new the change shift into the
national kind of system so that
we know and we have full oversight of
what is going on with our schools
so just to put it into context within
the last 14 days
our my team in the outbreak hub we've
worked with 43 of our schools
21 of those have had five or more cases
within the last five
within the last 14 days and that doesn't
also account for all the inquiries that
we deal with
managing some parent inquiries as well
and the general support that we do give
so we are working with greater
manchester at the moment to understand
what the the next step will look like
what the national nhs test and trace
offer will look like
but also protecting that early
intervention that we've got a really
good strong handle of
eleanor i don't know if you wanted to
comment any further
yes i was just going to add to that that
the system we've got and the
relationship that helen and kate and
members of their team have built up with
the schools has been phenomenal
and we don't want to the new system the
new national system
may take a little while to bed in and
also um the reliance
on the child's um if national tests and
tracer talking to the child about who
their contacts are that that may well be
very effective with
older children but we're not convinced
that that will be 100
effective with for example a
four-year-old um
so we are what we're doing is trying to
make sure we've got a parallel offer
so that the schools can come to us
direct and we will support them with
that contact tracing and make sure that
that contact tracing is done
locally for two reasons one is that we
tend to find out very quickly when
there are any cases in a school and we
we do tend to hear more quickly than
than for example if somebody has to go
through you know if they get we tend to
hear at the point that a lateral flow
test perhaps is positive
rather than at the point of the pcr test
the other thing is that if there is an
outbreak in the schools it's down for
the local team to manage that outbreak
so it's in our interest to get on top of
it very quickly
so we are offering to the schools a a as
i say a parallel offer
to run alongside the national one it's
not contradicting the national one in
any way
but it just means that while we well the
national one is embedding
um we will have the confidence that
there is a local offer and that we're
picking up the cases and things aren't
falling through the net
so it's a it's a belt and braces
approach that we're offering to schools
obviously it's up to the schools to
decide whether they want to use
the local offer and i think we're all i
think across public health and all the
at the whole um educational world
children's world
we are absolutely determined to see
children back in in schools we cannot
continue to have the level of disruption
we've had
particularly as obviously most children
are not seriously ill from
from um kovid so we are really really
determined to try and keep children in
schools wherever
wherever we possibly can
thank you and it's really good to hear
that we're taking that approach
um any questions at all for helen from
anybody
i don't see any hands raised no one's
waving at me
before we then go on back to self
isolation pathfinder there is a question
relating to ben's input in the uh
in the group chat from councillor
newgross ben would you like to respond
to that
yes obviously this is relation to the um
the fact that evidently across the
country we are struggling in terms of
pcr testing at the moment
in terms of the question um bluntly i
think i am a bit concerned about the
capacity at the moment
um hopefully as um
we have the summer holidays coming up
there'll be less demand from schools so
we should see that
and start to help out a little bit but
at the moment it seems like we do have
capacity problems and again that's not
down to the lab capacity um seemingly
it's because
they're not able to open up enough slots
because um
presumably many of the staff that were
working at these testing sites over the
past year
as the country started to open up again
more employment opportunities have come
along
and and therefore there's not as many
people now working out those testing
sites which is why they have reduced
capacity available
um i think as i talked just about before
i think
the best advice we can offer at the
moment is a asks people to keep checking
and b order that home pcr test which is
still available
um even on system at the moment um if
you asked good to go and access a pcr
test so i think it's something that
um we'll keep an eye on as much as
possible but but we are
at the behest of the national system at
the moment unfortunately
thank you for that ben uh thank you very
much indeed right we'll now return to
item five on the agenda the
self-isolation pathfinder update
kirsty you're very welcome to the
meeting over to you thank you
hi thank you and so
in terms of the self-isolation
pathfinder
and it's a gm initiative so traffic are
taking part in it and
along with all of the greater manchester
councils
so this is in addition to the existing
local and national schemes that we have
in place
so we have the testing trace support
payments
um which is 500 pounds and we have the
local welfare schemes through trafford
assist
for things like food parcels vouchers
gas and electricity
and the the self-isolation pathfinder
in trafford it's running from um
the 14th of june up until the 14th
until the 13th of september and
it what it's about it's about providing
proactive engagement within specified
areas
with people who've got a confirmed case
of corvid 19
so what that means is within trafford we
call
every single positive case in postcodes
um
m15 and m16 and ask them do they require
any enhanced supports with specific
questions
around what support that they might
require and
and it covers things like food provision
medicine delivery signpost into
financial support
mental health support a daily checking
call
so if somebody says yes once we make
that call then we follow them through
that process and provide that
intense engagement with them
and there's going to be no that's not to
say that
it's excluding anybody within the
borough
to access the enhanced support but the
targeted phone call currently only
reaches those in m15 and m16 postcode
areas
so in terms of outcomes um
what we've had today within trafford so
we've managed to contact
or successfully reach 62 percent of our
cases
and we're just seeing 20 of people that
require
enhanced support that's mainly around
the food or the waiting on
the decision for the 500 pound financial
payment so we're kind of trying to
sign post them off to that and
we've had a couple of positive case
studies where we've funded a family to
stay in a hotel um and also
funded some vouchers for a family that
were extremely poorly with covid
and also a casual worker within a school
who wasn't being paid during her
self-isolation period and
we report into a gm programme board and
that programme board feeds up to the
national team
the national team are really impressed
you know greater manchester have got
this
run in and off the ground and really
interested in the case studies and the
ideas
um that that were feeding into the
nationals so hopefully
that might shape some national picture
for the future for self-isolation
support
in terms of what other local authorities
are doing so each
um local
pathfinder is completely different
across gm some have similarities some
are really really different
some do door knocking for every single
case
um and some do home visits with
intensive questions
some do phone calls and promote
vaccinations whilst they're on the call
i think the similarities eyes that we're
not seeing
um a massive uptake of the enhanced
support that's on offer
and whether that's whether we're phoning
people
or we're doing that intensive
door-to-door visit
i think that's covers everything on it
is there any questions well can i thank
you i think it's a very welcome
initiative
and uh can i ask will you be prepared to
attend
uh our future meetings to give us an
update
and we'll add it to the agenda yeah
that's fine chair
thank you we'll do that in future any
questions please from anybody for
uh for kirsty
i don't see any hands right kirsty thank
you very much indeed we look forward to
seeing you at our future meetings thank
you thank you
um moving on then we're going to go to
uh
mass vaccination rebecca
thank you chair good morning everybody
um so
i think a couple of things that i wanted
to update and have already been raised
so
um i'll just cover those and some of our
plans at the moment so as eleanor
referenced in trafford we are delivering
really significant success still in our
mass vaccination programme
um over 82 percent of all of our
population have now been vaccinated at
least once all of our eligible
population
and um out of that that 88
of people have already received a second
dose so it's it's it's really quite
phenomenal progress and
just in terms of the questions asked
about our most vulnerable population and
our care homes
staggeringly we've got 97.9
of over 80s vaccinated i don't think
there's ever been performers like that
across the vaccination program so that's
fantastic
and 98.2 of care home residents
vaccinated
and this figure does fluctuate due to
turnover
but most of the reasons for not
vaccinating our care home residencies
around
um their their illness or the fact that
they've tested positive or they've just
been discharged so it's not necessarily
about hesitancy it's just about their um
status at the time as a couple of people
have mentioned we are looking at the
care home
staff vaccination um take up and we now
are asked to do a weekly sit rep into gm
for those care homes who have got less
than 80 of their staff vaccinated
so that's about three three or four
homes in trafford
and so what we've done with um in
partnership with our local authority
colleagues is
done a letter out to those care homes to
ask what the reasons might be if there's
any change in that position and what
else we can do to help so i know a
couple of them have responded to say
actually
staff have changed their mind and so
we're going to do some targeted um
vaccine delivery at those homes and then
as hell i mentioned as well that kind of
approach as well to kind of education
settings or
any other settings where we can do some
some targeted work
um on that we ran our first pop-up
clinic to we a week and a half ago
um at kellogg's on trafford park so
that was about taking the vaccine out to
a kind of working age
um population it was a real success and
it was really um great to be there we
had both second
and first dose pfizer and astrazeneca
available and we did about 150
vaccinations on the day
so there's been a lessons learnt
document produced and um we are now
using that to look at additional
kind of approaches to businesses so
traffic center for example have
asked if we could do something else some
of the sports venues
we're looking at so we've we've not got
firm plans and when we do obviously i'll
bring those back to that group but what
we've got now is a
as i say kind of a checklist of what we
need to do in a lessons learnt documents
that we can start to take the vaccine
out to people rather than um you know
await those coming in
um and the other message really for
today is that we are seeing now
as anticipated a slow down in uptake as
we move through the younger population
so that's not come as any surprise
and that was something that we planned
for it's not unique to trafford
and it's a regional and national issue
and and i know ellie's on the
course will probably do the more
detailed update but the community
engagement team together with the
operational team
and the ccg coms lead are working on a
really specific
comms plan for the younger population
including some case studies of younger
people who have contracted covid
what the messaging needs to look like in
terms of communication channels
and again how can we take the vaccine to
that population
who traditionally don't necessarily
access their gp so um
i won't steal ellie's thunder but um
that's that's my update for today
thank you rebecca i have a question from
kahn
yes thank you um
i think even though a large proportion
of people actually have
had their vaccinations still there are
people who are not had vaccinations
and that is a bit concerning my question
is really this
the ones who have not had their
vaccinations are these people who have
been in the
care homes for a long time or are these
people who've just been admitted
because that could actually give a
reason why
everybody's not been vaccinated
so in terms of uptake within care homes
as i say the uptake is really
significant we're talking about tiny
numbers
of patients within care homes and the
reasons for that are
as you've mentioned and i've mentioned
either um
been discharged out there's a turnover
or recently admitted or
recently had covered although that's not
an issue at the moment because we've not
got covered outbreaks in care homes
but when those patients are discharged
and they are under the care of their gp
it is very easy for us now to check a
person's vaccination status so they are
being followed up
individually um by the gp in in that
situation
the broader statement that you make
which is absolutely right there are
still some people who
um will not or have not
or declined quite vociferously the
vaccine that is the work that we're
doing the community engagement team to
truly understand
the reasons and previously it's been
about access
about demography about age and and those
things so
it's it's about targeting our
intervention at a very very specific
level whether that be age
ethnicity or at geography so we continue
to do that work
and we'll continue to do it as we plan
for the booster
so the guidance was issued again about a
week and a half ago on the booster which
is likely to be in the
kind of um originally identified cohorts
prior to cohorts um
starting from september and into the
winter
so september to december looking at both
the booster vaccine
and the flu vaccine running in parallel
so
still a lot to plan and we need to just
keep learning from the messaging
of the feedback that we're getting then
make sure that we continue to do that
targeted work
thank you
thank you are there any further
questions councillor blackburn sorry
council blackburn
okay thank you um could i ask
about the vaccination of our
been men and been women because i've
been told that
certain rounds have not been able to to
go ahead
because of of covered issues um
have has there been an offer or do do we
have any
any evidence of lack of take-up of
the offer of vaccinations to them
so i don't have the data to hand in
terms of that particular workforce group
they should have been
invited now as adults to access the
vaccination
i know eleanor and i were involved right
at the beginning in terms of looking at
different
workforce groups and we prioritized many
workforce groups and i think the
refuse collectors were included on that
if that's been reported as a specific
issue
and then eleanor and i can pick up
outside of the call how we identify and
prioritize those individuals for a
vaccine eleanor i don't know if you've
got any further info on that
no i haven't um and we have had some
cases obviously
on some of the rounds um but the bin one
uh and women have all been included as
part of the age-based program
because they're not part of the health
and social care workforce so they will
all have been
invited as their age cohort became
invited
um and certainly from the council point
of view we are also we're strongly
encouraging all of our staff to take up
vaccination
um so we can have a look and see um
whether there's any any gaps in that
in that workforce we can pick that up
outside the meeting
and we will continue to encourage um we
are continuing to encourage all of our
workforce
to get vaccinated as soon as they can
including taking um
time in work time has been allowed for
that
yeah could i just ask it it's it's there
a possibility of a mobile unit going
to that you know the place of work so
that
you know it's it's accessible to that
particular workforce
absolutely so um the work that we
trialled as i said at kellogg's was
about how we approach
businesses or places of work and so if
that's another
place of work that we need to
concentrate on and deliver a pop-up
clinic to then that's absolutely
something that we can consider so i'll
feed that back into our um program group
no problem at all thank you rebecca
and can i thank councillor blackburn for
that question because it is a
um an issue at the moment we are being
told that
rounds are being dropped because of a
cruise absent through covered or
isolating
and so if we could just pick that up
eleanor with um
with chris morris maybe or
is it helen ashcroft who's our waste uh
client side
to see if there is anything we can do
and if we need to get down there to the
base at
where they work from in wooden ships we
can certainly do that
um but as some councillor welton has put
in the chat of course
if you're a close contact you would have
to self-isolate and
and we also have obviously at the moment
seen a lot of parents having to sell
fights to
stay at home because of looking after
children as well so um but yes we'll
definitely look up
look at that with chris and helen you're
right councilman does make a very good
point there thank you
uh any further questions at all for
anybody for uh
rebecca i don't see thank you rebecca
moving on then community engagement
nigel
yes thank you chair i'll just give a
quick update on some of the activity
from the community engagement team
so last week we did some work in the
community in the sale west area which
was linked to the community center there
and alongside the bread and butter thing
the focus there was very much on
promoting self-isolation as well as
vaccination messaging and just a couple
of key headlines from that from the
people we spoke to uh 70 percent of
people had received both vaccinations
almost 60 of households were regularly
testing and over 60
were aware of self-isolation support
available
and we are going to do some further work
in the sale uh more area next week
that's the plan
uh we're continuing to work uh a focused
approach in the north area and in
particular in the old trafford area
we're going to do
some work over the next week
particularly ground to real
really promote the clinics in the area
promote vaccine take up
try and get some further insight into uh
why there still may be some uh um
why the take-up in in of the vaccine is
still not happening as a high level in
that area so we're going to do some
further work in there to get some
further insight
we've also got there's a gm um
initiative going on over the next two
weeks which is a funded street team
called
eyewalkers and an advan as well so
they're going to be going out with uh
max chat material to encourage people to
get
vaccinated so they've got leaflets where
they're going to go out and give those
to the public
but also some facts chat materials
they're going to give to businesses like
hairdressers barbers cafes bars things
like that so that um
for those that choose to they can help
and advocate
for the take-up for the vaccine so that
is like i said it's gm wide initiative
and they're in trafford
tomorrow and next week on the 21st of
july
um in terms of you know just general
support doing as much promotion as we
can particularly for
the uh pop-up and walk-in style clinics
that we're seeing now for example at
limelight it's been something elmston
some
um in partington as well so the comms
team have supported us with getting some
good
uh leaflets posters uh banners off as
well as well as using social media
um as as already mentioned uh by rebecca
uh the comms colleagues are working on a
campaign to encourage younger people to
take up
uh the vaccine uh so those plans uh
ellie's bringing those to the
vaccine group tomorrow for us to look
through and we'll be supporting that
through the engagement scheme through
our
uh action plan over the summer
um in terms of the uh with the
restrictions ending the team will be
reframing the conversations that we will
be having with people
uh whilst continuing to obviously very
strongly focus on pushing
uh the vaccination take up as a kind of
key central message
uh but with the conversations that we're
having we really want to get a kind of
temperature check uh with people in
terms of how they're feeling with the
restrictions ending and this move from
rules to guidance and that'll be really
helpful for us to help
shape our work and also some of the work
of the other teams
um eleanor has already mentioned has has
asked the team to start looking at
promoting
that kind of healthy lifestyle messaging
as well which will be
helpful in you know people being as
resilient and and healthy
as they can be going you know into the
autumn and winter and we'll again build
that into
some of that summer activity uh ellie
just asked me to mention
uh that there's a new campaign
coming from the government next week
which is going to reflect the new
guidance and advice so we'll wait
to see what that says but i'm also aware
that uh on a great manchester-wide basis
they're currently revising all the kind
of gm wide comes
and the campaign approach on the back of
the easing of the restrictions
so as i understand it the approach is
very much going to be around
supporting people and businesses through
the transition from regulations to
advice
and encouraging people you know to keep
doing their bit as eleanor said i'm
pushing those core
public health prevention messages such
as behavior such as hand washing
uh meeting outdoors you know getting
tested if you've got symptoms
under vaccination messaging
uh just one final thing i wanted to do
was just to give
a uh update around volunteers so last
week
we had a meeting with volunteers a
forum which we called the voice of
volunteers and we wanted to get feedback
from
volunteers that have been working
particularly vaccination clinics
to get feedback from them on what
motivates them to be a volunteer
what the barriers and challenges they
face um how they would like
additional support also to get their
thoughts and opinions around shaping
and helping to code of co-design the
sort of vision for uh
volunteering and traffic going forward
so that was a real real useful meeting
got some real good feedback and we're
going to be meeting with those
volunteers probably
on a monthly basis going forward and
just to mention as well i know i've
mentioned that previous meeting we've
got our volunteer officer now in place
which is claire mcguire she's been in
post now for around a month uh
doing some brilliant work already she's
quite
coordinating a lot of activity around
the volunteers at the clinics but is
also helping to boost the volunteer
there's that we have so we've got a
wider pool of volunteers available
uh that was it that's not fake for me
thank you nigel and i just say i took
the opportunity of going out with the
community engagement team in south west
last week and it really was
a very good session and not only that
they were able to
actually identify uh one particular
individual who was desperate
desperate for uh the vaccination
and just couldn't get to where he was
being offered which was lark hill
which is four bus rides and they very
quickly
arranged through the red cross to get
him directed to the pop-up clinic at
limelight
and he's now had that that's the first
back and he's booked for the second back
as well
so and that's that's really really
impressive work that the team are doing
there
and it's very important we do pick up on
these people and and
it's working any questions at all i've
got one linda blackburn
you could you just ask them you know
with regards to comes
with with the the the start of
um the football season and
um obviously fans visiting the grounds
would would um you know places like
manchester united lancashire cricket
altering and traffic football
would they be prepared to have any any
sort of
signage encouraging people to get
vaccinated
either signage or something over the
over the speaker a couple of times prior
to matches starting
yep i think i can come in there so i
think absolutely that's part of the
comms plan and we're also working
closely again with um colleagues to see
if we can go beyond that and actually
offer some provision of
um vaccination pop-up clinics maybe not
at the ground at the same time before
so we are in active discussion about
that but but yeah i think the
ability to advertise essentially at
those um
venues and those events is a really good
opportunity that we can't miss
okay thank you thank you councillor
butlin
uh any other questions at all thank you
nigel can we move on there to helen
grant on the community enforcement helen
yeah good morning chair um so as you're
aware the enforcement group
um now meets less frequently um as
there's probably less of a role
um for enforcement going forward
the number of covid related type
complaints that we get in community
safety
and also to greater manchester police in
trafford
is now very very low indeed and
what we're actually seeing is more our
normal patterns of crime and anti-social
behavior
for the time of year um which have
probably kind of
resumed um as if crime sort of dropped
in some of those traditional forms when
we were in
lockdown um but that's now kind of back
to normal
so i think they in terms of the teams
within the counselling regulatory
services it's probably environmental
health
who are bearing most of the pressure
around this in terms of business
outbreaks and
advising businesses in the borough
and obviously we've kind of talked this
morning about the relaxation
of some of the measures and different
views
around face masks and face coverings
i think that's potentially a source for
conflict with our
residents so i would just urge people to
be
respectful of each other's views i have
contacted
um transport for greater manchester this
morning i know the um
there's something in the chat from ellie
she was saying
um it's very much a live um question
at the moment and they are in
conversations with the mayor's office
because
they do have the opportunity to
introduce bylaws that could potentially
mandate face coverings as i understand
it so um
that's yet to be decided upon um
and then just noted from what nigel had
said that he mentioned
the use of advanced and that there's a
gm
wide approach to that we're doing some
work around community
safety where we've got the use of
advanced as well so i've
linked him with ellie um he's doing the
comments for public health because it's
a two-sided
screen that you can put videos and
pictures on
and so we're going to use that as well
to help promote the vaccination program
and where you're having pop-up clinics
and and so on and so forth so
that's kind of where we are at the
moment is
similar across partners in terms of
greater manchester police and housing
and but around enforcement that is
probably tailoring off
now and probably the focus is more on
engagement
and those kind of vaccination programs
and then
just to mention that a new chief
inspector has started with greater
manchester police in trafford
um over the last week and so
i'm sure he will he will meet everybody
in due course but just to make you aware
of that
anyone got any questions for me well
thank you helen and i think uh
when you start to move to guidelines the
the obviously clearly the need for
enforcement is uh
uh very much diminished uh any questions
at all for uh helen
helen i don't see any hands raised at
all anyone waving at me
um morning mike it's caroline it was
just to echo what helen
said i've been i've been on the call um
i have asked steve to make contact with
everybody via email and introduce
himself and he's extremely busy
with the things that are going on in the
sale west but he is slowly getting
around to
meeting everybody virtually thank you
caroline i was wondering who was on the
iphone
thank you very much um before we
move on eleanor can i ask would it be
okay to bring
ellie in just to talk around some of the
messaging uh i don't steal a thunder
about tomorrow's meeting but
it'll be really useful to hear some of
the things that the work she's
involved in and and the messaging going
forward
if that's okay with you yes that would
be fantastic and ellie's been working
really hard and particularly on
messaging for younger people and so on
so
um we're very very very pleased to
ask ellie to join thank you ellie
hi yes so um essentially we identified
the need to
start promoting the vaccination um a
couple of weeks ago particularly with
people under 30. we've now revised that
as people under 25 just because we feel
that 18 to 30 is
too big of a catch-all group to take one
approach to
um that you know so like 12 age year gap
so
um the vaccine group meets tomorrow so
myself and jamie oliver the ccg
comms lead i've put together a bit of a
plan um
which includes um a digital advertising
campaign
so that allows us to be on platform
social media platforms that we don't
have accounts on so the face the
council have got a facebook account and
a twitter account but depending on what
the detail of the spend
is um we can be on things like snapchat
tick tock instagram and we can advertise
to them
um whilst also trying not to make it too
counselling
um so we're not sort of saying traffic
council are asking you to
it's going to be a little bit more
anonymous than that um so that
like nigel said the vac chat um
campaign for greater manchester sort of
expanded now to do the same thing so
they're having a really strong two-week
campaign now to really push
and advertise two people under 30 and so
that's running which includes um a lot
of digital advertising
but also that will be advanced and
um i'm not entirely sure what an eye
walker is but i
assume that it's people walking around
with various advertisements on their
backs
um there is as helen said uh helen grant
said there's also some other digital
advertising
that we can take advantage of for that
um and then there's um basically the
vaccine group tomorrow we'll be asked to
sort of feedback as to
where we think people 18 to 25 might be
so if we want to take it off
digital platforms where we go then and
obviously
we can engage with universities but
obviously we're into the um summer
holidays now
so it's just been a little bit more
clever about that
um at the moment i think it's fair to
say that a lot of the concentration is
on the vaccination program
and i'm just continuing to encourage
people and i think
there are more and more pop-up clinics
which we are advertising
um where we can um online but also
we've now got more and more um actual
assets
to support community engagement ccg
colleagues to promote those
um in person so um yeah there's a lot
going on and there's obviously a lot to
plan
with the 19th of july and coming up and
as the work that nigel talks about
encouraging healthy lifestyles more
and obviously we'll need to make sure
that we've got a plan around
the public health priorities going
forward ensuring that we've got
um consistent messaging with that and
the greater manchester approach in terms
of encouraging responsible behaviors i
have seen
a draft of some tfgm messaging which
encourages strongly encourages face mask
wearing on public transport
thank you ellie uh any questions at all
for early from anyone
uh councillor blackburn
sorry it's me again just wanted to ask
um
could you just ask with regard to the
traveller community
um a few well quite a few travelers
turned up on kingsway park last
yesterday evening and i'm just wondering
how
are we um sort of communicating with
them
because obviously they're going from
from place to place
um and do do we have any indication if
there's any take-up at all in in in
vaccination or
or you know sort of what what what kind
of sort of concept or
communication we're having with them
um i don't know if nigel is better to
comment on that
with his previous role but essentially
when i think public health are informed
when
um we're made aware of travellers um in
a certain area and engagement with them
is
is arranged i'm not sure if that was a
health visitor
last time i don't know if nigel helen i
think we sort of tried to get that to be
more of an nhs
representative so they could check on
health of children and other things as
well as
talk to them about testing a vaccination
at the same time
yeah i mean i could just quickly in
terms of the council's role
uh the regulatory services have a role
firstly
dealing with illegal encampments but as
part of that they will do a general kind
of
check to see how people were and to
check there's no kind of immediate uh
health issues but as ellie said uh
during the pandemic we've also been
linking up with
health visitors and getting them to
visit as well
um so i i don't know in every instance
because i know there have been a few
troubles but i know
um certainly um one of the most recent
ones the feedback i had was when they
were asked a question around
vaccinations that they had been
vaccinated
that was the feedback that we've got but
i i don't know if that has been the case
in every time but they are being asked
that question
and then give an advice of where they
can go for a vaccination if they want to
have one
thank you nigel is that okay for you
counselor batman
thank you um any further questions at
all
well i don't see any therefore that
really is any of the business at all
i don't think there's any other business
at all for us today that therefore
brings us to the conclusion of this
meeting we'll meet again in a fortnight
um and we'll probably be in a better
position to talk something about
what's happening after the 19th of july
and and the effects of that
can i thank you all for your attendance
again today and can i also
add my continued thanks to our staff
across public health
environmental health regulatory services
community engagement team
the communications team as well ccg
and all of you involved in trying to
combat
this pandemic and keep it under control
in trafford thank you very much for
attendance and have a good day